[Music]
my tongue is so excitedly titled
talk about an idea a SSS opposing - some
does the whole thing sound really
obvious pretty simple it does like most
things have you wants to the side
effects to life so first major question
you should be asking yourself is why she
listens mean just germinating and start
a conversation currently writing meta
base which is an open source project
which we'll talk about later in a
flashback to my previous life hearing
Paul talk about git and github metrics
I'd actually started a company around
analyzing convinced of something that
and joining uh catalyst first date
assigns the president's and in a past
life those mo researcher and after that
the head of data science tiny so I
managed to see and the interaction of
data science analytics reporting general
standard engineering as well as having
bounced on my screen for the Y so what's
all this did is it's nonsense it sounds
kind of obvious you have a data
scientist you're an analyst they're
clearly doing something with that data
and the fundamental of motivation for
this or the reason even talk about it is
there's a very printable sequence of
events and desires and habits about you
and on the dashboard or deck or your
presentation so it starts off with can
you give me more analysis of people to
sign up in Malaysia awesome it's great
for ego to notice it every night have
filters you know the end is over someone
who's studying a product launch
somewhere and there's twenty thirty or
forty he's the principal or in requests
from factories so awesome
how do we break down by gender having
break down by incoming at such a general
how it blah blah blah Oh someone so just
notice that there's this connection
between fraud rates and a coupon code a
tradition two weeks ago now if you're in
the middle of that it's probably going
to stop from doing anything interesting
today so the endo reduction or people
look at it they get really excited
thank you master stuff at some point you
know all the stuff you're talking about
around and now the flows and pipelines
exciting things all get hijacked by just
oh can you answer this next question so
having seen that play out in my career
and my friends recruiters and every
company advise Hospital in six or seven
years maybe in head of that like keeps
happenings and maybe change how we do
things a little bit and going into it a
little more concretely you know that
when you hand something over intelligent
person can look at it and that they're
gonna have something handsome and have
some simple questions other than that
there are things you can predict when
you just sort of throw it over the wall
hey here's this chart here's this
dashboard years attack basically the
only the questions got asked of you and
then you ask and prosperity against
people who are around that presumably
are around it because they care because
something about that part of launching
Malaysian matters is somebody and
they're probably going to have some sort
of insight some sort of early questions
and it's just some ability to
meaningfully interact with it and the
real thing that's wrong with all this
pissed you're in the middle of all of it
so anything interesting you're playing
I'm doing with your day week on gets
hijacked anytime
yes liver something value so if you
throw dashboard over the wall and no one
cares about your day the second you do
something valuable or useful everyone
come at me like oh this business so how
to fix this
well the good news is in gently
disappearing so I'm a huge fan of this
sort of business that's some ways entire
DNA databases eight lanes here and the
key thing though is as you are planning
to end things off just stop and pause as
you're making that final Center
presentation and think about making that
data that you're using for that final
step intelligible all on its own so
handoff to normalize data and off things
that can display more beings and of
things that the average intelligent
person or company would open up and
Excel and be like oh I know what these
columns be I can slice and dice this
I've used pivot tables let's pretend and
I'm going into how your end users we use
this obvious dumb thing as Google sheets
or so or I'm here and I'd say it's
notice a little the in terms of what
motivates is we're an open source just
analytics platform our whole thing is we
do some magic animate okay how to be a
model build ontology I'm all out of it
and legend normal human beings just
click around and figure this out so for
thought for a minute installs anywhere
in equal minutes mr. database and we're
pretty much just super silly the super
easy turn simple way for normal humans
if I'm lucky this will work and it
should kind of show you what the end
user experience is like one thing that's
throw out is all this is produced here
config so out of the box you essentially
get interactive driving interactive of
varying ability to generate like
explorations are dashboards and all this
is useful life with much anyone that use
bounce so I think is pretty cool Espino
peers but life on this couple 10,000
companies use it so so now going back to
the real reason the air which was trying
to spread the gospel of don't I don't
dashboards like there is a question for
why you versus your botanist so
presumably you're doing a job because
you wanted the job and you guys you care
about the coming to your work yeah
ideally we carry the project you're on
when you have done something you want
other people to actually is it as
opposed to talking to ether and so the
more accessible the thing that you hand
off is the more generic it is the more
someone who doesn't like isn't you can
interact with it and figure out what's
happening is generally getting value
that you don't expect from all say the
more respect your company the other
thing that starts to happen as you adopt
this mindset is you start having better
data sets in around other uses so if you
have a clean data set around user
behavior you can generally height of
that interview I wish I thought you can
generally like makes it match things you
can generally really put them into build
and employ simple hospital specific
users so for example marketing sales
don't we talk the same language all the
time and having data set that marketers
sales in their stance makes it really
easy to spin up a little mini apps for
ourselves or for marketing or whoever so
this is kind of where I get into a
little bit of technical stuff I think so
all this should hopefully obviously need
very dependent on your underlying data
set in your audience so at some point a
normal human being will read those
column names playing around with fields
and columns and so start off with user
Gilbert's
radiations are cool and make hong short
like just use real words not everyone
knows how txm stands out if you're gonna
use jargon use their target so if you're
talking to marketing people don't use
any target they have their own set of
vocabulary it's useful to learn them
learn that language and speak to them in
their language use words as they're used
by your target sir so this sounds really
really stupid in August but it's
actually contrary so protip bookings and
revenue were not the same and there are
people that will freak out if you excuse
them because the numbers look weird and
some more obvious things replace news
with actually texting the five because
no one's you remember what zero is a
tube is not really one of my favorite
hobby horses is get rid of test data
most places that run things at scale
have all kinds of crops in the database
and you know things like soft deletes
and things that you don't
yeah another thing is all that table
skipping and why table where everything
in the column headings is straight
English or whatever language your
company ism is better than a bunch of
small tables don't person a combine
normally means donors influence I don't
so this is a really contrived example
hopefully will give you a sense of the
flavor of how is the seeds so over
analysis we've got a user table been
stable there's very helpfully user ID
events table and so so one of the first
questions is what are you enrichment
wine
so obviously people think about users
nothing about offenses it'll probably
want to enrich the immune system which
is weird and not what you're probably
going to forget enough DSF if you're
doing this in detail then you probably
enrich the defense table and you
probably try to have that consume all
its own most people you talk to if
they're thinking about using
demographics and behavior they'll be
centered on these end users have done
things so as annoying as it is and as
tedious as it might be to keep adding
columns as saying is the first event
last event of certain kinds and it's the
first login last login this is the first
five action last by action and then
another thing that is common scripting
or analysis is just creating a table
where giving users rights on certain
days now all that's going to drive yours
do not talk to me later but assuming
that you believe it on next steps are
you can generate those into any table
this is a bunch of sequel Darrow nice
Suffolk right sequel these days still
taking it too seriously this bottom one
right sample dataset and create this
Hughes n to pi day you then join with
activity table to create at the
normalized sense of where where it uses
all from and usually this point people
free calendar life but I've got a
petabyte and so you've probably not
gonna hand over a petabyte of a subway
though it's kind of shocking how large
data sets and how large data set people
and literally Korean with if you set
things up right so at some point like
where things Andrew and let it happen
and I think another table Detroit is the
museum there's something magic that
happens when people can slice and dice
things in a second imperfect people
start fighting on their stuff one of our
great users I use the stories is there
was a floor worker at the flower
shipping Factory we discovered a set of
lot of transactions because they kept
shipping roses to must work at airline
somehow this seems really weird someone
that was like a white manager
this coupon go to Michigan I poked
around use us I've actually found oh
there seems to be this parchment can
Punk looking at passed around it's
unclear they were found that until way
later but there is just something
imagine it happens when everyone just
tap around with my things
really and that's also 2018 things like
energy now like compared to how life was
a tenement here's our life my analyst
career like it's like a college budget
that's all the staff $5 for every how
many loved espresso machines problems so
that's what so at this point things good
morning so you've got this data set and
try to like figure out what users want
what they'll probably want next and say
just start anticipating what the next
right dimensions are just start doing
all the basic stuff around you wonders
the thing is if you're handing this off
to be sliced and diced by normally them
being they're not going to be able to do
a lot longer calculations so do it for
them like I think are interesting
suppose to golf is one of those things
where it's been feel pretty special
taste it's a lot less specialty waste -
and they are going to come back in your
life
pool so you know give me the distance
from our headquarters in Zurich
as opposed to grab revenue at that point
it's useful to also just kind of revisit
what is it was typically in early stage
certain earlier stage interesting
exploration so you probably did a lot of
it
the original TSM so this is a great time
to do that again and see whether the
hanging wall has any weird anomalies of
it chances are this artifacting chances
are making mistakes as a really good
time to use just go through it like you
know me as a reporter like you wouldn't
Revere state an expression that's right
well I think let's talk to you claim the
news or anything and the reality is they
don't because datasets exist they're on
each tooth that's somewhere they are
supposedly going and they're great so I
was really proud of them and known that
nobody knows they exist so at some point
the process of ending oh that data said
hey John Kenny this is the thing I want
you to see everything matters this is
where we should I think it was very
simple and easy free it's all five
minutes etc and the ability to send
someone willing to collect hey here's
this thing that I created take a look at
it and most people have given a choice
between an interactive dashboard and
really not to pay the SEVIS folks in
your network take a lot every time
questions concerns death threats thank
you so I have a good question one thing
that I guess like I said the philosophy
of your tool for what I understand it's
like my invention is like demoralizing
where she can write correct there's a
database for some animals depends on how
certain work so if you're dead certain
the transformation is super valuable to
it so the most part you do in your own
lives you will want to create some sort
of intermediate able to calculate being
wrong in this case was just taking my
day also if someone that's used to
everywhere to record and it has really
huge history into like 10 20 50
different reports if you're like hey I
think this thing might be interesting
you probably want to use is enjoy and
fine later if it's luck Starla if it's
great without the staff that said that
you think about it as how far upstream
you go is how essentially how rigidly
you're creating something was training
it depends on how right you are
how do you concentrate and the larger
the force consequences are the more
certainly more jerking push and one
great example what happens if you push
all the way up is appeared in
association with your clients before
even touches the file data warehouse
like the session nice things
I can rant against the post hoc sessions
nation of their employments I don't
never like a quick phone to accident so
also link let's let's imagine that right
like I've tried to eat normalize
everything like everything that I
thought of but inevitably there's some
things I miss time some things I like
what he's doing and I'm like they
mention like a normal users can
understand coincident like a great like
a percent very frustrating so I ordered
some strategies and things to get around
that in those cases
I mean the honest answer is turning
their wrong that's fine
they're gonna find stuff and in some
ways so the idea that there's going to
this magic process that proves out is
that aspect and this is though it's you
know for the final table they're just
about how things work it's gonna be
messy it's gonna be the morning how much
people were so you know this thing's
little wrong nothing's little wrong and
in many way it's just bad that is the
game and so it's more about getting good
that cycle automating the production of
these things means as a process I just
emotional budget like you're gonna do
this as many another to be Savino how
much is a magic
so for what I see I think that one of
the key selling points for this
technology is easy to use yes and the
young ease of use I'm curious as to what
and additional differentiating factors
this product has to some of the other
technologies out there like that
Roger Society yeah I think yeah I think
the biggest difference is that were not
ready to offer analysts we're too cool
for people they're being strong-armed 2
million Dutch words
Sebastian we have missed electrolytes so
we're not necessary the most
fine-grained typically things as I
mentioned edibles primarily something
that automates the creation of first six
slides as well so if you think about us
as final and so that sounds kind of and
wavy but it actually cascades to like
what features we have works install it
who installs it for the most part
in the ideal world what kind of a finely
done thing where install us and curing
the datasets and then you're in users
figure out their emails they could throw
in fashionable words and in many ways
it's as big a job from her periscope
remote where girls to us as it was from
cognos past August to tableau I if you
look at things are pretty tough
tableau is all like deadliness I have
expression as I do you like dragging
dropping imagine the traders transform
everything I think we're kind of similar
jump or it is just usability is just I
can use that how easy is it does create
a different style use for a 17 but they
do priesthood that like annoying certain
numbers and he hands over dashboards
just anyone who fiddling futz tap around
you